I figured our continued
hey youtubers is Charlie so Game of
Thrones just posted a new viral trailer
for season 5 so there's going to be a
breakdown of that footage as well as an
explanation of what they're gonna be
doing it's all about aria gets into some
Bravo stuff so careful for minor
spoilers from specific Bravo locations
in the city it's just gonna be one of
like the big new locations the show does
in addition to Dorne you should all be
very excited about it it is gonna be
badass real quick reminder - I'm naming
the first winner of my weekly telltale
Game giveaway if you want to enter that
I'm giving away a new copy of the game
every week all you have to do is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video real simple so here we go starting
off we see Arya having a waking dream
it's not specifically a war dream
because we're seeing visions of the past
she remembers killing the Frey Guardsman
after the red wedding while the how just
watch there with his jaw on the ground
that was the end of season 3 then she
remembers killing Roark after she and
the Hound came on that dying man in the
village remember where the heart is that
was late season 4 I like that that makes
it sound like the heart is in season 4 I
guess her heart kind of did die a little
bit but that was mostly in season 3 and
after Ned Stark was killed then she sees
herself giving the Braavosi coin to the
ship's captain in the season 4 finale so
we're jumping around in time quite a bit
and then the first time I saw her wrap
her fingers around this pommel I thought
it could have been from back when she
killed biter but she was wearing
different clothes then and her arm looks
really clean so I'm thinking that this
is from before she left King's Landing
there haven't been a lot of times she's
tried to pick up a blade that's clearly
way way too big and heavy for needle is
like the size of a large turkey knife
and that looks like a big broadsword so
it's probably just from season 1 the
last shot though that's the cool one you
all probably recognize the black and
white doors as being the entrance of the
house of black and white and Braavos for
people that haven't read the books
that's the temple of the faceless men
the order to which jaqen H'ghar belongs
i have already done a couple bonus
videos about the faceless men
specifically and Braavos so I'll just
add links for those in the description
if you guys want to learn more about
them that's about it for a ten-second
trailer it's not much but it's teeing up
the idea of future viral content being
released like little snippets of stuff
HBO is trying to push everyone to this
viral website the three-eyed Raven calm
where you can sign up for mobile alerts
via text message and Twitter I
personally would recommend going with
Twitter just because text messages are
gonna cost you money I do most of my non
video communicating on Twitter - just
because it's super easy so I'll link for
my Twitter in the description - if you
want to follow me there for Game of
Thrones related stuff HBO does something
a little bit different every year to
promote the next season so the big
question is is what are they going to be
releasing like what kind of content
first off the bat I don't think we're
gonna see a full-on trailer for awhile
last season we didn't see the first
official trailer till like four weeks
before season 4 premiered so I would
expect the first big trailer to come
around that same time that's like the
end of February early March they'll
probably use this three-eyed raven stuff
for images like really short clips maybe
behind the scenes stuff I wouldn't get
your hopes up too much but it'll be
something I mean something is better
than nothing really the interesting
thing I think is that they chose the
name three-eyed Raven I mean it implies
a lot of things one is having Future
Sight as in we'll see things from the
future through this site because the
three-eyed Raven has future site via
green site the other side of that is war
dreams we haven't seen like a whole lot
of war dreams but it's possible we could
see a lot of that season 5 so they could
be teeing up some of that using this as
like a back door there were a couple of
wolf vision promos for the stark
children last year I wasn't a big fan of
them but I do applaud HBO for trying to
get creative with their marketing the
funny thing about using the name
three-eyed Raven is is that we're not
supposed to see brand on screen at all
during season 5 that doesn't mean the
story is not going to invoke him or use
any devices related to him it just means
that the actor who plays bran will not
be on screen even if they are teeing up
more Ward dreams I don't think that
we're gonna see a lot of Jon Snow up at
the wall of all the things they could
tease for season 5 if they're not gonna
do like full trailers
I think they'd focus on Braavos I mean I
think that'd be the smartest thing to do
if I were HBO and I wanted to get fans
like super pumped up about season 5 I
would show off mostly Bravo stuff it's
like the next big location that we
haven't seen a lot of before if you want
to do learn more about stark children
war dreams and stuff like that I did a
video about that a couple weeks ago so
I'll just add another link in the
description I really am hoping we're
gonna see a lot of Aria and Braavos and
this viral content I mean it's probably
not gonna be much it won't be like
full-on clips
it'll just be images probably get like
really notable things there have been a
lot of rumors about what might be
happening in Braavos of all the
characters in season 5 I think Arya will
be closest to her book character so if
you do want to learn
specifically what she's up to then just
read books four and five she's one of
the few characters that does have story
that goes on in books four and five most
characters most POV characters are just
localized to one of those books if you
have read the books just please use
spoiler tags if you want to comment
about what she's gonna be doing in
season five or might be doing and a lot
of you are asking about Aria theories
for next season I will say my biggest
theory right now is the jaqen H'ghar
will be back and they'll replace a
really big character in the house of
black and white with the actor that
plays jaqen H'ghar or they'll kind of
tie those characters together there are
a lot of theories about the character
that I'm talking about I'm trying to be
as non-spoilery as possible but you get
the idea I think the jack and agar will
show up just speaking as a fan I totally
love all this viral stuff that HBO's
doing but I feel like the telltale Game
is going to be a way better marketing
tool especially if it's a legitimately
good game which is supposed to be I
haven't played it yet but they are
sending me an advance copy I think
they'll be selling the game in like the
next two weeks so you guys won't have to
wait that long they just put tales from
borderland on sale right now this week
so they might wait till next week or the
week after to start selling the game
officially pre-orders are open which
actually reminds me congratulations to
Hanna M you are the first winner of my
weekly telltale giveaway just message me
on my channel for details because I'll
need some contact info it's basically
gonna be like a Steam pre-order for
people that want to pre-order the game
right now on Steam they're offering a
discount it's $25 normally it's going to
be $30 the quite lower the price after a
couple months though whenever I start
posting videos for that when I start
posting gameplay videos I'll post them
here first on this channel and then I'll
move it to my video game channel there's
a link for that in the description too
it's just called Charlie streams for
those that are asking the six episodes
of The Game of Thrones telltale game
that are coming next year I don't think
that the season pass is part of the
pre-order I think you have to pay extra
for those they'll probably be releasing
those like once every two or three
months but it'll be a lot of fun and
because we're moving into like the
winter season and a lot of TV's going
away I might have some extra time to do
more Game of Thrones bonus videos so
feel free to leave requests in the
comments just a reminder I have new
mobile links up here they're the same as
the links that I add over here totally
the same stuff right now click here to
learn more about the faceless men and
click here to learn more about Braavos
thank you so much for watching so it's
all high five I'll see you
tomorrow
you